there are a few things more upsetting
than the idea of a lonely death to pass
off the mortal coil without anyone
around you anyone to comfort you in your
final moments thankfully
scp-4999 exists to help solve this
tragic issue
scp-4999 is a humanoid who appears
dressed in dark formal wear he manifests
as the side of fatally injured
critically ill or otherwise dying people
within the last 20 minutes of their life
he will only appear to those dying alone
sitting or standing with them if no
chair is available in an act of what
seems like silent respect next he'll
pull out two cigarettes one for himself
and one for his dying friend he'll then
hold their hand place a hand on their
shoulder or engage in some other kind of
comforting physical touch in their final
moments then disappear shortly after the
person has passed leaving no trace that
he was ever there except for the left
behind cigarette while no one is exactly
sure what he is or why he's chosen to
keep his vigil thanks to scp-4999
nobody ever really dies alone